Bonjour à tous et bienvenue !
Dans le "making of"
Des clips de l'été.
On part en fin d'après midi au Portugal,
Pour tourner nos clips demain et après demain.
Mais avant ça
On s'est fixé
le projet
de se transformer,
en des "stars" de hit de l'été.
Maintenant plusieurs stars de hit de l'été qui s'affichent à l'écran.
En gros, on doit ressembler à ça.
Je ne me suis pas lavé les cheveux,
depuis six jours..
Parce qu'il fallait que j'ai un maximum de sébum.
Pour protéger mon crane.
Et vous savez quand j'avais seize ans..
J'ai fait une allergie,
cette photo de la prof' d'anglais.
Ça m'est arrivé dans la vraie vie..
Heureusement qu'elle est très extrêmement compétente,
on a fait un test d'allergie.
Et au final, tout les produits qui sont la je ne suis pas allergique..
J'insiste car j'ai eu un vrai traumatisme,
si vous faites une teinture.
Faite un test avant !
Vraiment c'est hyper important ! Faites le !
J'ai pas précisé pourquoi on va au Portugal.
Car il nous faut un temps de rêve..
Et quoi de mieux que le Portugal pour faire ça.
Ah ça gratte !
Oohhh !
Tu fais moins le malin maintenant... Hein ?
Carrément, j'ai plus envie de rigoler non plus.